in the aftermath of the massacre in
texas president biden is turning his
attention to the so-called gun lobby and
earlier today said this
about the second amendment watch
we must ask when in god's name will we
do what needs to be done
to not completely stop fundamentally
change the amount of the carnage that
goes on in this country
second amendment is not absolute
the idea
that an 18 year old can walk into a
store
and buy weapons of war designed
and marketed to kill
because i think that's wrong
it just violates common sense
all right on sunday the president and
first lady will travel to texas to meet
with the families of the victims and
meanwhile over in washington far left
democrats are intensifying their calls
for more firearm restrictions like
massachusetts senator ed markey who says
it's time to pack the supreme court to
make sure that gun control laws aren't
struck down take a look
we have to take
very seriously
the threat which an illegitimate
far-right supreme court poses to gun
safety in our country
[Applause]
we have to
expand the supreme court to get back to
two stolen seats that the republicans
and donald trump took from the american
people so that we can ensure that when
we put gun safety laws on the books they
are not overridden by the supreme court
of the united states
shameful bit earlier tonight at the nra
convention in houston the 45th president
donald trump warned against disarming
law-abiding citizens and laid out his
plan for school safety here it is
when joe biden blamed the gun lobby
he was talking about americans like you
and along with countless other democrats
this week he was
shamefully suggesting that republicans
are somehow okay with letting school
shootings
happen they're not okay with it this
rhetoric is highly divisive and
dangerous and most importantly it's
wrong
it has no place in our politics what we
need now is a top to bottom security
overhaul at schools all across our
country
every building should have a single
point of entry
there should be strong exterior fencing
metal detectors and the use of new
technology to make sure that no
unauthorized individual can ever enter
the school with a weapon
all right well here for reaction
republican senate candidate in nevada
and former attorney general in his state
adam laxalt along with arizona senate
candidate mark brnovich who is the
current attorney general of the grand
canyon state gentlemen welcome aboard
let me start with you adam if i could
you know when i hear this is what we've
we see this people complain that these
things keep happening there's never any
change part of it is
because all this political rhetoric
sucks all the air out of the room nobody
gets to to the i suppose more boring
solutions like school safety you know
doors uh
hardening those targets and you can't
raise money on that necessarily and so
we go from one to the other with these
people who've been in washington for 50
years and then they they still complain
about it how do you see this playing out
when everyone still returns to
legislation politics blaming etc
you know people want leadership
and for president biden to rush to the
cameras that night without the full
information and once again
blame 100 million law abiding gun owners
is an absolute disgrace people want to
know why we can't fix these things
because washington
trots out the same attacks over and over
we looked at this when i was attorney
general we met with law enforcement and
the exact same solutions you're hearing
today we proposed a few years ago every
time you see a breakdown in
communication you usually see that the
school and the local law enforcement did
not have proper training they didn't
have a shooter response you don't have
single entrance and you need to make
sure the door the classroom doors
actually close
we have been asking for armed guards in
schools for a very long time it's
democrats that refuse to allow that and
so this is a tired deal and i hope that
americans will reject this because this
is not going to protect our kids we need
real solutions and we need them now you
know it's understandable mark you know
we've we're
understandably emotional we
understandably want major solutions we
want things that are going to make a
difference and yet we we do notice that
it's almost as though some problems the
politicians don't want to have go away
right we also know that we can have
these ideas but they also have to be
implemented right they
you can throw money at a problem have
these strategies but if people don't
implement them properly
we have an issue and and if we like with
that man that ran from the barbers with
the barber's rifle in order to make a
difference
those would be the guns that would be
gone that that we would be relying on
just the police and we've seen in this
particular instance what happens when
you're relying just on the police with
the firearms
yeah tammy
all of our hearts broke when we saw the
story i know that many of us have been
praying for comfort for the families and
praying for peace in our community and
our world and i think one of the things
we're not talking enough about is what
has happened in this country in the last
30 years that this evilness that's kind
of perpetuating to younger and younger
kids and whether it's the effect of the
media or video games it is having an
impact and at the end of the day the by
administration the democrats are trying
to politicize this issue but if more gun
laws worked chicago would be the safest
city in america and we know that there
are places like your previous guest was
talking about in israel if you go to
places like st or i have been the border
gaza every single one of the members of
that community is armed because of the
worry or the of terrorist attacks they
harden targets and we know here in
america we guard our banks we guard our
money we guard casinos
with armed security and yet what are we
doing to our most precious resource our
children and that's why local
communities need to come up with
solutions that include you know making
sure doors are locked making sure that
we have the proper security in those
classrooms including police officers
adam it's interesting a lot of people
did pull out of the nra conference and
there's a thing called projected
identity
where one side projects we know about
projection in general but projects a an
accusation about who someone else is
and if you hear it enough that someone
else adopts the false projected identity
and i see conservatives doing this on
issues of morality on issues of what who
they are and what matters if you hear
you're racist long enough maybe you'll
begin to believe it
people pulled out of the nra convention
when in fact it is american citizens who
are members that that's the lobby uh and
it's a continual kind of
libeling of the average american citizen
when this is exactly where we go each
time
this is a time for courage
not a time to back down when the media
when the democrats when hollywood
professional sports franchises when they
go all in on something you better
believe they're wrong on the issue our
voters and americans want us to stand up
for them they are the voiceless and so
we went through this with the blm too
you know as a former top cop to watch
republicans not stand up against the blm
riots to not stand up and defend law
enforcement it took weeks before they
thought it was safe enough to go out and
defend these institutions we need people
out there today right now and those that
did speak today like senator cruz and
president trump you know god bless them
because it's the law-abiding citizens
that deserve to be respected they
deserve to be spoken for and guess what
in the last few years a lot more people
have understood that self-defense is
paramount in our community and we need
more defense for our schools not less
yes and we you know
law enforcement the police clearly have
been under fire have been denigrated you
can understand how that's depressing has
an impact on on their sense of self and
also the desire to become law
enforcement all of this has to change as
biden is attacking law enforcement again
and as they're saying they want to take
firearms away from law-abiding citizens
everything they do gentlemen makes
everything worse and this is no
different adam and mark thank you very
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else